durante la noche del miércoles al jueves
se produjeron nuevas detenciones en mi
armar sumando ya más de 220 personas
encarceladas entre ellas el
vicepresidente de la cámara baja del
parlamento un familiar de aung sang suu
kyi y varios funcionarios locales a
pesar de ello los manifestantes
siguieron saliendo a la calle este
jueves por sexto día consecutivo
[Música]
es hora de que la policía y los soldados
tengan claro si sirven al país o si son
obedientes del tirano
30 minutos
además la junta militar último una ley
de ciberseguridad que le permitirá
llevar a cabo apagones de internet
prohibir contenidos y reclamar datos de
los usuarios denunciaron cerca de 160
ong mianmar mientras tanto en rangún
este jueves se sumaron a las filas las
minorías étnicas
hoy es el día de la revolución de los
diferentes grupos étnicos que se apoyan
mutuamente para que el país vaya en
contra de la dictadura militar
la escalada de la violencia contra los
manifestantes con varias personas en
estados graves ha sido condenada
internacionalmente el miércoles joe
biden aprobó sanciones contra la junta
militar el presidente de eeuu dijo que
washington impondría fuertes controles a
las exportaciones además de estar
preparado para imponer medidas
adicionales esta semana